welcome everybody to the first session
of
to the keynote I have to say I'm very
happy with the turnout if somebody
actually told me in before that putting
the words acid and database in a title
of a talk presented a strange loop will
draw a crowd I would actually be
skeptical and I'm extremely happy that
seeing you all here
so first just few words about myself my
name is attila i am currently serving as
senior software engineer at the at fauna
and I'm working on fauna DB witches are
distributed and yet as a compliant
database which I will be talking to you
about in the past I've been doing a lot
of things
so before faun I was at Oracle in the
java.lang tools group so I actually
worked on the Java platform I have the
JDK Dino link packaged in there to my
name which helps you with implementation
of dynamic programming languages on the
JVM and I also did work a lot on the
NASS one which is the JavaScript runtime
that was shipping with JDK they decided
deprecated in the newer releases Paul
because most of the team including me
left they feel a little bit bad about it
but you know life goes on and before
that I was at Twitter where I was at the
runtime systems team I spent quite a lot
of time doing
jaqen performance tuning games and
scaling distributed systems and I in a
past life also served as a maintainer on
the several open source projects I
worked Mozilla Ryan among the if on the
on what is now Apache free marker
template engine apparently everything
that touch either starts out or
eventually becomes either a distributed
system or a language one time not sure
why that happens but it seems to be a
recurring theme in my career and
funnily enough the distributed database
actually happens to be both of those
things at the same time so our agenda
for today just see approximately where
do I want to take you with all of this I
want to touch on why are we even
building another database and then I
want to talk about how did we implement
actual strong acid compliant
transactions in a distributed database I
will talk about our transaction log
implementation how this helps this
achieving this goal I will talk how we
are balancing eventual versus strong
consistency in our system we are always
strongly consistent though and I want to
end the talk we're discussing two
interesting things which is applying
control theory to your distributed
system to actually make it faster it's
it's hard enough to make correct
distributed systems and usually when you
make them correct sometimes they might
have some unwanted latencies and
fortunately there is a bunch of control
theory concepts that if you you know
rediscover in it nothing new is nothing
is ever new right so these things that
were known in the 60s and if you apply
them to a software system you can you
can actually achieve some fun results so
to answer the question why do we need
another database I admit I did fail for
this slide from our marketing material
because I want to establish a little bit
of context but I'm not I'm I mean far
for me to try to sell anything I'm the
I'm the worst salesperson in the world
so I'm really concentrating on the on
the technical stuff here
so basically relational databases are
fine and an established thing where we
do have transactions and they're very
well understood in the in the business
world but then they don't allow you
usually from global distribution
multi-tenancy temperatures all things
that we would love to have when I say we
would love to have fauna was actually
founded by several of my ex Twitter
colleagues and then attracted about
other X Twitter people like myself and
the five second elevator pitch for fauna
typically is we're building the database
we wish we had when we were at Twitter
and this includes these things and the
typical loss equal fair also is not
particularly appealing to us because
they do achieve scale but again
transactional guarantees usually fall by
the wayside and typically businesses
always must make bunch of trade-offs so
do you want data consistency if you want
this to be scalability do you want
developing flexibility you know pick one
and so this is what we set out to do
with with fun we try to just basically
take the best of the both worlds
there's a bunch of core innovations in
the infauna
and I don't want to go through all of
these these these are all properties
that are highly desirable in a
well-designed database system I will be
touching on the right bottom corner
which is temper ality because I need to
speak about that and I will not talk
about anything else except for the
distributed asset transactions really
here so this is the one thing that we
will focus on mostly today so let's see
what it is about there is several ways
to actually implement asset compliant
databases in a distributed system ours
is one of them it's it's not the only
one obviously what we do and the best of
my knowledge we are the only only only
company that's trying to ship ship an
actual production level implementation
of it is Professor daniela body and
bunch of other authors introduced the
paper in sigmod in 2012 titled calvin
the fast distributed transactions for
partition database systems and my
colleagues those who originally founded
fauna found this paper and figure that
you know what this would be a good idea
to try to build a product on that the
experiment is ongoing so far it seems
like you know
it's working out it is similar in a
bunch of properties to Google spanner
and I won't really be talking about
spanner or talking about comparisons
between Calvin and spanner you can find
me in the hallways after the after the
talk if you want to talk about these
kinds of things or anything similar
suffice to say that Calvin is is seems
more palatable for us because it doesn't
require custom hardware or synchronized
clocks Google is doing terrific work
with spanner and they are also doing
terrific work with providing runtime
system for it where they have clocks
synchronized to a very small known
uncertainty uncertainty but they need
specialized hardware for that so what do
we do here
Fona is both horizontally scalable and
it's it's a multi-value concurrency
control store this means two things we
do the database stores data in multiple
replicas every replicas contains all the
data replicas are typically stored in
different geographies but you can have
them anywhere and within a replica they
are charted into into a number of
partitions so this here is meant to
present you a single replica with with
three or four partitions the temperate
the temporality which means that we are
actually storing for every role we are
storing historical values as well
actually means that you can go back in
time and query the database anytime in
the past so
and you can have replicas in multiple
regions so for the sake of this
explanation let's imagine that you have
three machines in San Francisco three
machines in Washington DC and that's it
because normally we don't suggest you
run less than three replicas but that
wouldn't fit on a slide so we'll just go
with two here and what happens
what's interesting typically is when you
are running transactions where people in
different regions are trying to touch
the same date that that's where it gets
interesting right as long as they are
just running completely unrelated
transactions it's not particularly
interesting so let's imagine that we
have two customers both want to buy
widget number three and we have customer
two in San Francisco and customers six
in the Washington DC replicas both wants
to buy it and we only have one in stock
so both of them would be running pretty
much the same transaction make sure
there's one in store at least make sure
that the customer has enough store
credit to buy it
subtract one from the stock and subtract
the price of the widget from the
customer store credit so these are two
transactions left resume that they're
running at approximately the same time
in both places so we have the San
Francisco replica we have the Washington
DC replica one client connects to the
San Francisco replica tries to run this
transaction another connects the
Washington DC replica and tries to run
this transaction what happens at first
they know that when you go back one
slide so the note in each replica in the
upper right corner we will presume that
that notice our query coordinator it
runs the transaction so what it does it
it reads those rules for for both the
customer and the widget it will probably
need to fetch them from some other nodes
in the replicas because we try to do
well we're doing more or less random
partitioning right now so data is just
scattered in the replicas so it will it
we'll pull the data from other nodes in
the local replicas the node in
Washington will do the same except it
will be doing it for another customer
and then it will calculate the set of
Rights so what you have there is that
the numbers in red say okay so I check
the stock the customer can buy the visit
I need to write a new value for the
store credit and they need to write a
new value for in stock which is zero the
same thing happens in Washington DC the
customer there has a lot more money so
instead of 21 for him we write back 421
when he wants to buy the thing and what
we do now is we submit so both replicas
will be submitting these transactions to
a transaction log transaction log is
defined by a consensus protocol we do
use a interestingly modified version of
raft we do have an interesting the
modified version of everything really
and and these transactions which will
we'll get into the log the log will
guarantee an ordering it is not
guaranteed there's no guarantee really
which one of those transactions will get
committed to the log first it's it's one
of those you know dirty little secrets
of distributed systems basically that as
long as you did not act back to the
client you can reorder all you want
right so you can just claim that the
order was whatever so one of those will
get into the transaction log first and
the other will get in the transaction
log second what we also ship with the
transactions is the time stamps and the
keys that were read we are not taking
any locks when the transactions are run
rather we are using instead of
pessimistic locking we're using
optimistic locking so as part of the
bundle that goes into T 10 and T 11 so
the data that comprises the transaction
is both the right effects of the
transaction and also the read keys and
the read timestamps the slides here
don't the slides here are written as if
we are sending the values that were read
but we're actually standing out sending
over the timestamps it's just as good
it's actually better and eventually the
knows that stored data in every replicas
will be reading the log and they get to
t10 and both the san francisco replica
and the washington replica will read the
transaction and they need to rerun the
reads at the transactions new time so
they need to rerun the reads at t10 and
see whether they still match what the
reads that are in transaction this is
the optimistic concurrency this part of
the optimistic concurrency control and
if the reads happen to be the same we
just write the new value to the
underlying data store with the timestamp
of t10 what you can see here is that
both replicas that even though they are
geographically separated will arrive at
the same decision they will
deterministically reads the same data
because all the replicas contain the
same data we will start start from the
assumption that all the replicas contain
the same data so when they rerun the
reads locally they will see that nothing
has come in between t10 and when it was
run and modified any of the rows so it's
safe to apply the apply the write
effects of this transaction to the
underlying storage I'm not saying commit
because technically commit is commit
already happened when the transaction
was made durable in the log you can't
lose it then anymore so we call this
face
and now the next transaction
t11 comes along and both replicas are
running it and they are reading and that
they they do the same thing they need to
reread the the data at the now at
timestamp 11 and what they will notice
is that there is a difference because in
the case of t 11 the role for the stock
the role for the visit and the value for
the stock in there already has a new
timestamp T 10 and it was read at t 7 so
it means that the transactional level
lost the transaction 10 in the in the on
the optimistic concurrency check so it
needs to abort and it can
deterministically abort both in San
Francisco in Washington DC so this
transaction at this point is is aborted
what is important to see here and what
is actually a pretty nifty property of
this is that all the cross system
coordination only happens with achieving
a consensus on the log itself after we
achieved the consensus on the log the
nodes that are applying the transactions
are reading the log so even if they fail
even if they're shut down even if they
lose availability and come back later
they have their own persisted well known
index they just start reading the log
from there reapplying and they
eventually catch up and all will catch
up in the same deterministic manner of
course there's no silver bullets and
there's no free lunch there is obviously
an additional element here additional
computation really which is that when
the nodes in a particular replica are
applying a transaction they need to do
they need to redo all the reads and some
of those reads will be removed and if
the transactions right effects actually
affect several nodes then all of them
will need to ask for the reads from each
other so there is definitely benefi an
additional like quadratic component to
the tank that we typically try to
mitigate bye-bye
well eagerly reading and in broadcasting
within a replica so when a transaction
is a when a node is applying a
transaction for which does have right
effects it will have to read its own
storage for its local subset of reads
that it needs to perform for the
optimistic concurrency check and then it
will send them to other nodes in the
replicas that are affected and other
nodes will check up will receive those
cash them if needed and then when they
are applying the transaction they will
actually consult their own cash first so
now it's this hard the groundbreaking
but it's just one of those things where
we are trying to optimize something and
minimize the minimize the amount of work
that needs to be redone this protocol
actually and as I said we have an
interestingly modified version of
versions of all the protocols that we
use this is not vanilla Calvin vanilla
Calvin as as described in the paper does
not run the transactions on a
coordinator so what we do we run
transaction on one node we compute the
write effects we gather the reads and
send those to other nodes which will
then redo the reads vanilla Calvin
actually requires you to encapsulate the
logic of your transaction in the
transaction itself so the transaction
basically like shipping limit programs
that need to rerun deterministic lis on
all nodes and that obviously also has to
mean that those little programs can be
termina Stickley we get rerun on every
node so they better not try to get the
current system time invoked random
function your file I or anything not
like we are actually doing any of that
but it's it will it would be in most
cases would be computationally even more
expensive because you would need to
rerun the whole
of the transaction on every note so as I
said we don't need clocks we don't need
look we don't really need locks well
optimistic concurrency control is kind
of a locking except different but but
and and and we don't have to rerun the
transactions on on every node as such
but we still need to do the the
rereading the timestamps for for the
concurrency control so how are we doing
the transaction log because we transact
so in the previous slides I just told
you that you know well yeah we have a
transaction we tossed it in the
transaction log it gets reread and gets
applied well okay and so far it's a hand
baby I just hand waved it away that yay
we have a consensus-based transaction
log how does it look like so in order to
have asset transactions our transaction
log is helping the lot with with it we
can guarantee that if transaction is
always entirely written to the log and
that helps atomicity it's not the whole
story of atomicity but it definitely
helps the log the order transactions
which helps both with consistency and
isolation and finally once written to
the log the system can't lose
transaction so they are durable
well can't lose transaction so until you
lose more than a quorum of the nodes but
that's like the standard asterisk
disclaimer for all the consensus based
systems what we typically say is like
well run a lot of nodes it's funny
because you can you can get on a DB
developer edition which lets you run it
on a single node on your laptop really
but it's it's not it's not terribly
redundant you could say oh you really
need can use that forest to experiment
with it right
and then the data nodes will eventually
be reading those will be pulling data
from the log well the log is also the
log nodes are eagerly sending
transactions to data nodes if they know
that they are basically on the front of
applying them and if notes fall behind
they can pull so there's a lot of parts
of the system we have we have dually
both both push and pull
to ensure that you know the system just
keeps pumping so where is the log
obviously it's not in any one place it
is a distributed thing it's the log is
based on distributed consensus as I said
we're using raft we could be using faxes
as well it's it wouldn't be making any
particular meaningful difference I think
at least in terms of capabilities and
for log multiple machines will work
together to agree on what is in the log
typically what we do is with catalog
nodes across replicas so they I mean why
put all your eggs in a single basket
right so instead of having all the log
nodes being in a single replica we
prefer to have one log node in every
replica we have more of them but for the
sake of these simplicity let's let's
roll with one right now so what happens
is that clients connect and I have not
pictured the clients here so the little
green dots are the are the transactions
and the white circles would be nodes
that can act as credit coordinators
clients connect to them they run
transactions they prepare the batch
which is the transaction which is the
with the read effects and write effects
as I said and they send them into the
transaction log obviously node can serve
multiple purposes so it can be a
coordinator and the data log and data
node and the log node at the same time
so some of those can even be sending
transactions to themselves which
actually is pretty cheap they typically
follow if a node is both a log node and
the data node it will it will obviously
prioritize sending to itself because you
know sparrow network hub and then those
transactions end up in the the first end
up in the memory of the of the log node
at this point they could even be lost if
they know just crashes at this time but
then the coordinator is also still
keeping it so it will be
it would try to send it somewhere else
Calvin protocol works in a box we chose
an epoch to be ten milliseconds so what
happens is that the lock nodes will be
gathering transactions in memory until
10 milliseconds pass and then they will
gather all the transactions you have in
memory for those 10 milliseconds and
then wrote that write that as a single
message that they will write these
batches as a single message in the in
the transactional log multiple nodes can
write a batch for the same book so it's
there's no one to one correspondence
between an epoch and and the message in
the log because if all three of those
nodes that are in the log have gathered
some transactions in memory they will
all produce a message and now the green
dots are our current Apple can be
otherwise colored dots are meant to
demonstrate transactions from a previous
epoch that are already committed to the
log so they write them to the batch I'm
gonna save write them to the log this
really only really means that the
messages are being proposed into the
into the draft consensus system and
eventually when enough of them agree
that the message should be appended then
it's considered committed every log node
will store a copy of the resulting log
which is good because because then the
data nodes that use the log they can
only just they can just read it locally
and they can apply the transactions to
their data storage the system has both
as I said it has both pull and push
systems having a single nod log would be
a performance bottlenecks in reality we
they always recruit more notes notes to
be log notes and they will form multiple
raft rings so they will form multiple
multiple logs at this point we typically
switch terminology and say that we call
these each of those rings is a log
segment and when they are taken to get
they are the entirety of the log which
actually leaves you with an with a bit
of a problem because now you need to
merge these deterministically so carbon
is all about determinism and what we do
is each data node now when it wants to
apply transactions for a particular
epoch it needs to fetch them from all
the log segments and then
deterministically merge them when I say
deterministically merge them the several
strategies to do that we are not doing
anything fancy
we basically just number the segments
and say all transactions in segment one
for a particular epoch come first and
then all the ones for segment two and
all the ones for segment three and so on
we could be doing something more fancy
we could be playing with the module and
permutations based on the epoch number
to make it more fair right now we don't
friend I have works in FinTech industry
when I was explaining this to him he was
immediately like who my clients would
definitely be figuring out how to always
submit in in to the log segment one just
like Ken that edge my transactions will
be the first in every epoch I mean I can
understand the sentiment okay so nice
thing about the protocol is that it does
not actually rely on clocks for
correctness the epics time stamps are
logical in practice we do use on our own
deployment we do use MTP and we got so
helped me I had to write an internal
sync protocol which I mean I would never
I would never claim that any anything
like this is correct but again
fortunately we don't need clocks for
correctness we just need to ensure that
the log the epochs in different log
segments roughly keep to each other and
you know if possible also queue to the
real time so these are nice properties
to have even if you don't that at worst
what it causes is that if any log
segment is is in the future then any
transactions that are committed into it
will have to wait until other log
segments catch up so that data nodes can
then deterministically merge that
particular thing and I think in a system
we run
second right time out for transactions
so if it's cued more than 30 seconds in
the future compared to everything else
than those transactions would
transactions that work segment we'll
just be experiencing timeouts which
hopefully somebody monitoring the system
would notice but again this might affect
availability in this sense it does not
affect the correctness you can't ever
grab the data that way though so this is
the log as I said and let's see eventual
versus strong consistency we have a
moment in the protocol when the
transaction we know that his juror would
persist it so its effect will eventually
become visible but we don't know what's
its timestamp yet because remember we
need to actually merge all the
transactions from discipline segments
and it's the data nodes when they when
they merged everything and when they
apply they all independently but
deterministically arrived as the same at
the same time stamp for a particular
transaction so the time diagram looks
something like this so the client
submits the transaction to the
coordinator the coordinator submits it
to the log the log after the raft has
reached the consensus that he a we
committed it it will actually act back
if it's in memory buffer is full it can
reject it and coordinator can we try a
different one and at this point when it
got back a commit message it could even
act back to the client that's the first
dotted line we don't do that
it could only act to the client saying
hey your transaction is durable it will
eventually get applied and then you
would get a system with eventual
consistency we chose not to do that
eventually the transaction we get from
log node to the data nodes
there's the little OCC check arrow there
as well and the data nodes will all
achieve the same outcome which is either
I apply the transaction and this is its
timestamp or I had to abort the
transaction because it failed the OCC
checks at which point this information
again goes back to the coordinator the
client is still waiting we still have
intact to the client at this point we
could act to the client we have a
timestamp or a rejection message but
presume we have a time stamp right so
it's rather successfully committed and
at this point we could we could act
actor the client but maybe not all the
notes have already committed their parts
of the transaction so the the first note
that reports back the time stamp we
could already use that to act back to
the client
but if they try to read back now they
might be blocked and turns out
psychologically people don't like when
the reads are slower so you know we just
decided to to do a bit of a wait until
the local read clock on the coordinator
catches up that's interesting question
actually like how do you figure out how
much to delay the read clock and this is
only the time when we act back the
transaction with the timestamp and the
client retries does a read doesn't
another transaction saying the snapshot
time is now that the times them that I
got from the previous one he will he
will be guaranteed to observe all the
effects so as for the transaction
language itself we do not have session
transactions our model currently doesn't
support them so basically you don't
issue like with sequel you don't do
begin transaction and then through a GD
BC driver you issue an update and a
select and a delete and whatever but
rather a and then at the end you do a
commit but rather what we do is the
whole logic of the transaction must be
sent from the client as single requests
very similarly to how sequel store
procedures would work originally Calvin
had this limitation because it required
all the transactions to actually execute
on the on all the nodes we don't have it
as we could actually as we actually run
the transactions on just a single
coordinators we could be keeping a
session there right so for multiple
client server requests round trips we
didn't implemented it because the
language itself is our query language is
actually very expressive so this is
taken from an e-commerce tutorial that
we have on our site and as you can see
it's it's very lispy if you're into less
people like it if you're not into lisp
then these days we also have a graph QL
adapter for our system so you don't have
to like lisp but for better or worse our
language is very less people
and this is hypothetically how it would
work right so the client could be doing
multiple round trips similar to like
select and update and delete and
whatever and and then when it issues a
commit that's when the coordinator would
be sending to the log and from there on
it all works the same as in the previous
example and we would eventually well the
only difference is that when the client
in this case would say commit they might
get back an exception saying that your
transaction was aborted sorry because
you lost the optimistic concurrency
check this is something we could do but
as I said people seem to be happy with
with the lack of session transactions so
far and saying it would always be the
case we could probably implement this
when we wanted to but it's interesting
doing that with this modification of
Calvin we actually have the ability to
have session transactions
technologically it opened the way for us
to have them alright so for the end of
the talk I want to talk about weather as
well like control theory aspects that we
put into the database actually we talked
about two one we put in and they had we
plan to put in so that one is always
speculative but you know that's a fun
idea so the idea with control theory is
let's presume you have something that
works correctly it's as I say it's hard
enough as it is to write correctly
operating distributed system and make it
somewhat faster
so typically coordination bottlenecks
latencies and so on
come come in and we can use things so
one thing that we do use infauna is a
PID controller it comes from
proportional integral derivative it's
it's it's a funny little feedback loop
for continuously modulated control
probably everybody has encountered it
because the cruise controls in the car
are an example of a PID controller what
it does is you always have a set point
right so and you know it's a car analogy
of course it's a car analogy you can't
escape a car analogy typically where the
cruise control you have a set point
which is the target speed that you want
to go
and you have a current process variable
which is the speed at which you are
going the difference between two is an
error value that you want to compensate
and the system the controller is doing
it by exerting a modification to some
control in this case in the case of the
car is the throttle however there is no
the system doesn't know the on on its
own it doesn't have a model of how
changing the control the throttle will
change the speed of your car right so
motors don't change torque instantly if
you are going uphill if you are going
downhill then the then the coefficient
of the throttle to the changes in speed
will change and obviously if your going
faster you need more throttle to also
compensate for the wind resistance
yada-yada so it needs to be continuously
modulating the system what the desired
properties of it are that you want
minimal delay and you want minimal
overshoot because in that case you will
end up with oscillations so the way it
works and I'm really sorry for throwing
mathematic formula at you is it it's
taking a weighted average really of the
integral of previous errors that's the I
and the derivative of the current error
and the actual proportional difference
in the error and how do you weight these
three because the K coefficients there
are actually the weights between the
proportional part and the integrative
part and the derivative part is with
which will give the characteristic for
the PID controller and it's a bit of an
art to tune the weights to make sure
that it converges rather than overshoots
there is a there is a fun little demo
for this which obviously features a car
that you can see so here you well if it
works
it is notoriously fatso
because I didn't write it so now right
now you see it working and then if I
move the car to a new position you can
see how the controller is actually is
actually compensating for for it and
then quite often you can also tell to
the terrain and then here you can
actually play with like what happens if
you you can play with like cancelling
out the proportion or the integrity or
the derivative leaving only just that
and see how that's the it effect whether
it will quickly compensate nicely
whether it will overshooting whether
it'll just asymptotically struggle to
reach the value but never actually reach
it and so on so okay so that's cars
right but what does it have to do with
with distributed systems what we use it
is to control when to issue backup reads
the backup reads are when there's a node
it needs to read a value the value is
not on its node it's on a different now
than it needs to it needs to read it
from the other node it presumes that the
other node is actually alive we have
several separate fire cruel detector to
detect nodes that are down so normally
the one that's local in its local
replica will be the one that its first
targets but if if it doesn't respond
within a bit within some time then it
will also need to issue a backup read to
unknown in a different replica in an
attempt to actually obtain the value
that it needs to read and the question
typically is when to issue the backup
read there are two extreme strategies
the one strategy is well issue a backup
read immediately always do two reads I
mean why not you can do it except you
end up with double the traffic on the
network the other extreme is well never
issue a backup read so if the first node
that you attempt it doesn't work time
out to the client let them retry not the
best user experience but it might also
work however if you do have a PID
controller in there then what it does it
can actually controlling this delta T so
the control
here is the time to issue the backup
read so it is the first read and if it
doesn't answer within the delta T then
it will issue the backup tree to some
due to some other node the process
variable that we use is the proportion
of reads that timed out recently but you
actually can go down and set it to zero
or you can set it to some ridiculously
low value that you want it to be
effectively zero like one in every ten
thousands or so if and if you set it to
zero though then it can ease can't
really ease back on its own so with PID
driving the time to issue the backup
reads the nodes will basically
automatically tune when to issue them
when everything is humming along then
the PID controller will just be
increasing the time until it increases
it passed the time out so will be they
they're never issued if parts of the
system start acting erratically things
are down then it will start shortening
the time to issue the backup reads and
it can pull it back all the way to zero
which basically means issue the backup
read immediately with the first three so
that's what we are using it for I was
also gonna talk to you about the common
filter but I think we're actually at
time I believe well you know what if
yeah it's time okay it will be in the
slides fun thing about the common filter
if they don't use it yet in fauna but we
are planning to use it and it's also
another little thing that in in in in
practice typically what you see it in is
in GPS system so when your phone
typically tells you like hey you're here
oh you know what you're actually here
and it pulls the little blue dot to
somewhere more precise so that that's
basically a common filter at work it's
taking data from multiple sensors
accounts for noise builds a bit of a
what's a quickly probability model and
then based on that it it it can achieve
a better value than what you would have
if you if you only had one of those
sensors or or all the sensors just read
separately and we also have a use for
that in a distributed system to speed
things up
unfortunately don't have time for that
so I'll just it will be in the slide
stone all right so summary we can create
database systems that are both
distributed as a compliant we use the
carbon protocol for that and Raft we
have a modification of the calven that
preserves its desired properties we
don't rely on locking or clocks which is
great and control theory can speed up
your stuff thank you for your attention
[Applause]